[ TIRES SCREECH ]
SWEET RIDE!
ALL IT NEEDS IS
A NEW PAIR OF WHEELS.
Narrator: TO TEST THE EFFICACY
OF DUCT TAPE TIRES,
THE TEAM'S STARTING OFF
A LITTLE SLOWER
AND BEGINNING WITH A BIKE.
HERE WE GO.
Narrator: GIVEN JESSE HAS BUILT
HIS OWN MOTORBIKE...
AW, NUTS!
CHANGING A BICYCLE WHEEL
PRESENTS NO PROBLEM.
[ GRUNTS ]
IS PART OF BUILDING
MAKING GRUNT NOISES?
[ LAUGHS ]
AND WE ARE DONE.
-WOW.
-NINJA SKILLS.
-HA.
-WE NEED TO BE METHODICAL ABOUT
HOW WE BUILD OUR TIRE.
I'VE TAKEN SOME MEASUREMENTS
OF A STANDARD BICYCLE TIRE
SO THAT OUR DUCT TAPE TIRE CAN
BE MODELED AFTER IT.
WE USE HALF-INCH STRIPS
TO FILL THE RIM
AND THEN FULL STRIPS TO MAKE THE
HEIGHT.
Narrator: WITH THE SPECS,
THE GUY GO TO WORK.
AND CANNAN HAS A SURPRISING
CONFESSION.
I'VE NEVER RIDDEN
A BIKE BEFORE.
DON'T GO TOO FAST.
THIS ISN'T THAT BAD.
Rachel:
AAH! OH, YOU'RE GOING TOO FAST.
[ DUCT TAPE RIPS ]
THIS IS PRETTY EASY.
LOOK, MOM, NO HANDS!
Narrator: SEVERAL MILES
ON A ROAD TO NOWHERE
AND THEY HAVE
THEIR DUCT TAPE TIRE.
-CANNAN.
-YES?
YOU HAVE A DUCT TAPE TIRE.
OH, YEAH.
Narrator: BUT WILL IT PROVIDE A
SERVICEABLE RIDE?
TO FIND OUT, CUE TWO
COMPARATIVE CONTROLS.
FIRST UP, REGULAR WHEELS.
WE PUT THIS CUP
ON OUR BICYCLE
AND WE FILLED IT TO THE TOP
WITH WATER.
GO.
Cannan:
AND SHE'S OFF.
AFTER EACH SET OF TIRES TAKES
ITS TURN AROUND THE COURSE...
Jesse: OH, WE'RE
EXPERIENCING SOME SPILLAGE.
...WE'LL SEE HOW MUCH
WATER'S BEEN SPILLED.
MY WATER IS BEAUTIFUL.
Cannan: THIS SHOULD GIVE US
AN INDICATION
OF HOW SMOOTH THE RIDE IS
BETWEEN EACH TEST.
-WHOO!
-YEAH.
FINISHED.
Cannan WE STARTED OFF AT 300mL
AND NOW WE'RE AROUND 270.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S SWAP OVER
THE RIMS.
OKAY.
Narrator: IF THE MYTH REQUIRES A
MacGYVER-STYLE SAVE,
ARE YOU READY FOR THIS?
I MUST BE CRAZY.
GO.
Cannan: OH!
Jesse: OH, GOODNESS.
THAT SOUNDS TERRIBLE.
Narrator: THEN THE REAL GAUGE OF
THE DUCT TAPE SUCCESS...
THIS IS A LOT MORE
THAN LAST TIME.
IT'S GOING ALL OVER ME!
Narrator: ...WILL BE TO SEE
WHERE IT FALLS IN THE SPECTRUM.
OH, SHE'S FALLING!
THIS IS TERRIBLE!
Narrator: BETWEEN A REGULAR
TIRE...
DON'T FALL!
[ LAUGHS ]
AAH!
TIRES ARE REALLY USEFUL.
Narrator: ...AND NOTHING AT ALL.
YOU LOST A CAMERA.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-AND ALL OF THE WATER.
[ LAUGHS ]
THIS IS THE WORST!
YEAH! [ LAUGHS ]
Cannan: YOU STARTED AT 300mL AND
NOW YOU'RE DOWN TO 85mL NOW.
NOW IT'S TIME TO TEST OUR DUCT
TAPE TIRE.
AND OUT WITH THE OLD
AND IN WITH THE NEW.
YEAH. [ LAUGHS ]
SHE'S READY TO RIDE.
THREE, TWO, ONE, GO.
OH, THIS ISN'T TOO BAD.
SO FAR SO GOOD.
THESE DUCT TAPE TIRES NOT ONLY
LOOK GOOD,
THEY'RE ACTUALLY KIND OF SMOOTH.
BUT THEY ALSO FEEL GOOD.
WORKING A LOT BETTER
THAN THE RIMS.
LIKE IT LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S PEDALING SLOWER
JUST BECAUSE OF
HOW HEAVY THEY ARE.
Rachel: I DON'T EVEN CARE
HOW THEY PERFORM,
I'M JUST GLAD
I'M OFF THOSE RIMS.
THIS IS GREAT, DUDES.
AND, FINISHED.
Cannan: THE RESULTS ARE IN.
THESE DUCT TAPE TIRES
ARE FANTASTIC.
Cannan: RACHEL DID PRETTY WELL
WITH THE DUCT TAPE TIRE.
WE DIDN'T LOSE MUCH WATER.
WITH THE RIMS,
SHE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH TRACTION
SO HER BACK END SLID
OUT A LITTLE BIT
AND THAT'S WHY SO MUCH WATER
WAS LOST.
AAH!
I THINK DUCT TAPE TIRE MIGHT BE
A VIABLE SOLUTION.